phase one he'll grab me
please and I will support his descent to
check my
stability phas one very static very
static he's going to grab
me support
his very
start he he doesn't even need to know
how to do bre fall cuz I'm the one
helping him
down all the test my
footwork okay make sure you grab your
nugget go okay uh phase two more
Dynamic but I'm still lowering him to
check my stability okay so it's not
static like this and I coming in so I am
using his motion
you you got to gra that I'm just going
to do
this so I Yi in
BO a yield
[Music]
in
okay let's
go so phas three I'm going to do the
same yield I'm going to come in but I'm
going to move out from under him once I
get him over I'm going to move out I'll
I'll try to assist his fall uh but it's
a little tougher to do so he's got to do
some so the yield and
out
po you can
see
yeld in
out
okay Bas three
go
for